[Musica]
ebbene mi ritrovo davanti a questa
platea interessante è la prima volta per
me questa l'emozione è molto molto forte
ancora oggi faccio una scelta cerco
appunto di percorre la strada migliore
possibile un bivio quindi questo è
l'ostacolo che ho trovato sulla mia
strada
ognuno di noi ha di fronte un percorso
percorso di vita
un percorso che lo porta appunto ad
avere una un'enorme esperienza alla fine
e a pensarci e soprattutto nel percorso
dare qualcosa a qualcun altro perché
anche gli altri ci danno qualcosa
quanti di voi hanno trovato un bivio
sulla propria strada
penso tutti e quanti di voi hanno
superato l'ostacolo che hanno trovato
invece sulla strada scelta da soli senza
nessuno
bene io ho dovuto scegliere
ho dovuto scegliere quando nove anni fa
ho scoperto di avere un processo di
osteonecrosi all'interno del mio
organismo all'interno del mio corpo
questo processo di osteonecrosi mangia
letteralmente le mie ossa quindi giorno
dopo giorno mi debilitava ha iniziato
nella parte inferiore del mio corpo
adesso ancora sto combattendo questo
avversario fino al punto di sapere due
anni fa che il mio destino era segnato
era quello di una carrozzina dover
vivere la mia vita su una carrozzina
a un certo punto ho dovuto fare una
scelta scegliere se dire bene non ho più
niente da fare
rimango fermo il mango immobile sul mio
punto e subisco quello che ho
oppure scegliere di combattere contro un
avversario che in realtà non conoscevo
io ho fatto la mia scelta
ovviamente sono dalla parte del
combattimento anche grazie al mio
background
ho iniziato a correre a correre su
questa strada una strada piena di
pericoli ostacoli ma soprattutto molto
buia
non sapevo dove andare in realtà ma
sapevo solo di andare avanti nel
percorso ho incontrato però delle
persone insieme a me delle persone che
stanno anche tra di voi nel pubblico le
vedo
e grazie a loro ho capito che da soli si
può correre molto velocemente ma solo
insieme si vince grazie a fuoco negli
occhi che loro avevano mentre guardavano
me nella mia condizione statica di
allora ma che comunque cercavo di
affrontare in modo sorridente anche
grazie a questi baffi
piano piano abbiamo iniziato a creare
delle cose interessanti insieme io
ovviamente non sapevo cosa fare
all'inizio si può solo di di spingere ad
andare avanti è la mia forza di volontà
aiutava anche gli altri intorno a me a
ragionare a capire qual era il vero
obiettivo e in che modo poter
raggiungere questo obiettivo piu veloce
nel tempo minore possibile perché
comunque era anche una corsa contro il
tempo
questo processo di osteonecrosi ancora
oggi esistente nel mio corpo ma una
parte lo debellata infatti oggi posso
camminare senza queste stampelle
oggi sono in piedi qui davanti a voi e
non sapete quanta libertà c'è nel nel
ritornare a camminare nel nel poter fare
questo
prima un passo e poi l'altro come dicevo
prima
questi passi ogni volta che li faccio
oggi dopo l'ostacolo che era
insormontabile per me da solo
gli faccio grazie alle persone che hanno
scelto di aiutarmi perché ognuno di noi
quando a un bivio di fronte deve
scegliere scegliere dove andare
anche loro hanno fatto una scelta e con
la loro scelta hanno influenzato il mio
percorso
il mio percorso poteva essere in discesa
oppure in salita con loro io ho avuto la
forza d'animo e grazie a loro ho ripreso
il mio sorriso un sorriso che avevo
perso inizialmente poi qualcuno di loro
per esempio mi ha detto perché non ti
fai crescere dei baffi visto che molti
mi dicevano che ero simile a freddie
mercury con i baffi che prima sono bene
perché no un barbiere un barbiere ha
iniziato a tagliare i miei baffi detto
ecco questi sono quelli che secondo me
potrebbero coinvolgere altre persone
in questo processo bene facciamo lì
qualcun altro invece addirittura mi ha
detto facciamo una guida per baffi una
guida notare alle persone perché tutte
queste persone che si rasano si rasano
praticamente fanno
tutte le barbe uguali i baffi uguali
perché non giochiamo un po invece col
nostro volto perché è quello che noi
guardiamo tutti i giorni davanti a uno
specchio ed è quello che ci fa rendere
conto se siamo felici oppure no il
sorriso
ecco abbiamo creato questa guida una
guida per baffi che abbiamo iniziato a
dare a tutte le persone
l'obiettivo era comunicare la forza
d'animo la forza di volontà per superare
un ostacolo poi qualcun altro si è messo
in mezzo e ha detto bene perché non
facciamo una raccolta fondi a questo
punto iniziamo a fare una ricerca un po
più approfondita su questo problema
iniziamo a trovare il miglior modo
possibile di risolverlo
e così abbiamo iniziato a creare questa
campagna che si chiamava un bacino per
ahmed
il problema è circoscritto sul bacino
per ora adesso sta anche in altre parti
ma questo è un altro dettaglio un bacino
per ahmed è diventato un simbolo è il
simbolo ero diventato io me stesso
i baffi il sorriso il fuoco negli occhi
che avevano le persone che erano con me
in questa campagna era lo stesso fuoco
negli occhi che a un certo punto ho
ripreso ho acceso il focolare che si era
spento grazie agli altri perché gli
altri hanno scelto questo fuoco negli
occhi oggi io lo vedo in tantissime
persone che mi hanno aiutato e nelle
persone che ancora oggi dicono bene
questa campagna ha avuto un buon fine io
sono stato operato poco tempo fa tre
mesi fa e ho vinto ho ripreso questo che
ho verso questo fuoco negli occhi che mi
mi fa emozionare ogni volta anche quello
che io vedo qui davanti a me in questo
momento il vostro fuoco negli occhi mi
dà una forza d'animo che mi permette di
usare anche le mie doti e dire bene io
ho scelto di percorrere una strada con
me hanno scelto altre persone e si sono
aggregate il mi hanno dato la forza
cosa posso dare io in cambio come posso
essere un elemento che può migliorare il
percorso di all
ecco io ho una piccola mania sulla
collettività mi piace mi piace citare
tutti quanti insieme
purtroppo il tempo è sempre lo stesso e
lo spazio soprattutto è limitante
quindi ho iniziato a pensare in una
lunga passeggiata nel deserto di lingua
negli emirati arabi perché nel frattempo
comunque le imprese che erano la scalata
al terminillo piuttosto che al gran
sasso proprio con queste stampelle che
sono molto deteriorate insieme a tutti
gli amici che mi hanno aiutato mi
facevano pensare
loro hanno modificato il percorso per me
e lo hanno migliorato
cosa potevo fare io per loro per tutti
quanti ho pensato al mio problema
il mio problema era derivato
principalmente da da una negligenza
diciamo così di constatazione del
problema in tempi pregressi
nove anni fa non mi è stato
diagnosticato quello che in realtà già
c'era sin dal principio era sempre stato
lo stesso è solo evoluto nel tempo ma
solo due anni fa io ho scoperto
realmente contro chi stavo combattendo o
meglio chi invece combatteva contro di
me
allora mi sono detto bene in questo
processo clinico c'è stato un problema
di analisi principalmente quindi come
posso aiutare gli altri ad una anno a
non arrivare a questo a questo bivio
questo percorso che è diventato anche
ostico nel tempo ho creato in questo
modo un sistema che raccoglie i dati del
paziente e li elabora e fa un match
making attraverso tutti i dati di altri
pazienti a livello globale
questo era il mio modo di poter aiutare
gli altri in tempo reale dandogli
l'opportunità di scegliere e di non
arrivare necessariamente ad un bivio
cruciale per la propria vita
elysium per me è stato è stato qualcosa
di rilassante di interessante
e di utile per gli altri oggi è in fase
di sviluppo questo sistema e con questo
io vedo la soluzione di varie patologie
come la mia anche osteonecrosi che viene
risolta in tempi brevi perché il
problema era principalmente derivante
dal tempo
io ci ho messo nove anni a comprendere
cosa avevo e ci ho messo due anni per
combatterlo
quindi anche io ho scelto in un bivio di
fronte a me ho scelto di non fermarmi e
di non dire solo grazie per il vostro
aiuto
io adesso percorro la mia strada da solo
ma mi son detto bene percorriamo ancora
la strada insieme
faccio una scelta anch'io con voi
insieme a voi e scelgo invece
quell'altra io faccio questo insieme a
voi perché gli altri modificano il
nostro percorso
questo l'ho imparato da questa
esperienza ho imparato ed è una cosa che
non avevo ben salda all'inizio perché la
competitività oggi è molto elevata tra
le persone e io invece mi son detto bene
la completa non serve serve serve la
l'organizzazione tra le persone e la
condivisione
in questo modo una società può elevarsi
in questo modo la società può sviluppare
anche le tecnologie che noi vediamo
d'altronde se ci pensiamo bene da questo
problema da questo bivio è nata una
nuova tecnologia una tecnologia che
aiuta anche altre persone e così via
questo è un nodo un nodo di tanti altri
che può sviluppare in modo differente la
nostra civiltà
quindi il punto principale è la scelta
la scelta di ognuno di noi che deve fare
di fronte a un bivio quando puoi aiutare
qualcuno fallo quando puoi mettere in
gioco le tue esperienze e condividerle
insieme agli altri fallo
questo è quello che ho imparato da
questa mia esperienza ed oggi io vedo
tante persone con il fuoco negli occhi
lo stesso fuoco degli occhi che gli
altri mi hanno mi hanno acceso di nuovo
nella mia vita
oggi voglio lasciare queste stampelle
qui perché grazie a coloro che mi hanno
aiutato
io non ho più questo problema ma grazie
anche agli stessi che mi hanno aiutato
io cercherò di aiutare gli altri in base
a una scelta che faccio
quindi vi ringrazio e spero che anche
voi in futuro sappiate prendere la
vostra strada e scegliere la scelta
giusta per continuare a vostro
grazie